les manifestants ont bravé le vent et le
froid troisième mobilisation populaire
contre la réforme des retraites ce mardi
à Tours Blois Vendôme ou même Romorantin
décorage encore nombreux cette semaine
grâce notamment à l'appui des lycéens et
des étudiants 1500 manifestants à
Romorantin 1650 avant dôme entre 5 et
10.000 la Blois et plus de 10000 à Tours
et dans le cortège touranjo
l'originalité était encore de mise du
côté des slogans anti-réformes Faustine
Luneau
pas l'âge de la retraite La retraite à
60 ans c'est pour maintenant près de
15000 manifestants à Tours ce mardi
selon les syndicats entre 8 et 10000
selon la police la mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites ne s'essouffle
pas et comme dans chaque cortège
quelques poètes et artistes amateurs
s'en sont donnés à cœur joie sur les
pancartes
son petit déguisement d'enfant et puis
le dossier à la retraite à la poubelle
qui les projets qui ont partir à la
poubelle aussi puis voilà attention
c'est un terme que tu disais autant de
royauté quand on voulait critiquer le
roi j'interpellé Macron lui dire que
même si j'étais d'accord avec lui je
dirais non à sa réforme parce qu'en fait
il a cessé sous les deux mentir
Elisabeth borne donc toujours l'idée du
chapeau de bouffon mais détourné en
corne de diable avec discrètement à 49,3
sur son front comme la marque du diable
de la bête pourquoi ça signifie pourquoi
en fait bah ça signifie qu'elle est un
peu mauvaise moi j'ai un cercueil des
deux côtés j'ai pas envie de mourir au
travail donc voilà c'est la symbolique
de dire non à deux ans plus quoi voilà
tout simplement le cortège n'a pas
traversé la Loire cette fois-ci
préférantes emprunter la rue des
Tanneurs moins exposé au vent froid que
les ponts Wilson et Napoléon les
températures étaient basses ce mardi
mais pas au point de refroidir les
ardeurs des manifestants présents pour
cette troisième journée de grève en
trois semaines de quoi réjouir les
syndicats c'est un mouvement sur la
durée je crois qu'on voit bien que il y
a des personnes qui se sont mobilisées
certains jours d'autres qui vont venir à
notre jour on voit qu'il y a des
entreprises privées qui sont présentes
il y a des des pancartes qui les
représentent aujourd'hui
quand bien même il y a des taux de
grévistes qui pourraient être un petit
peu plus faibles dans certains secteurs
les la manifestation elle est quand même
très importante le mouvement social
devrait se poursuivre puisque les
syndicats ont déjà appelé à se
rassembler à nouveau dans les rues ce
samedi 11 février
retour le rendez-vous est fixé à 14h
place Jean Jaurès